- Hello everyone.
Thank you so much for
joining us here today.
This is a Leader's guide
to Achieving Compliance
through Software Excellence.
A super exciting topic,
actually I think it's
a little bit exciting.
This guy here with me thinks
it's even more exciting.
My name is Tom Godden.
I am an executive in residence with AWS.
Our executive in residence team
is a team made up of
15 former CIOs and CTOs
from large multinational companies.
I was the Chief information
Officer at Foundation Medicine.
For those of you who don't know,
foundation Medicine is the
world's largest genomics company
based in Cambridge, Massachusetts.
And a lot of what we did and focused on,
in that was doing exactly
these types of things.
I'm very lucky here today to
be joined by my colleague Ian,
why don't you introduce yourself?
- Yep. I'm Ian Sutcliffe.
I am a principal tech
strategist in our healthcare
and life science industry vertical.
My background is primarily
in life sciences,
so medical device, pharmaceutical.
I've been anything with
architect in the title.
- Wonderful. Well, let's
go ahead and get started.
So this is a topic that I'm
sure you're all, like I said,
super excited about, because
maybe if you're like me,
compliance can feel overwhelming.
Maybe you're drowning in documentation,
or maybe unfortunately
you're just watching
your competitors move faster.
We've accepted as an industry
that innovation and compliance
are opposing forces,
that are things that we
cannot have simultaneously.
But what if that isn't true?
What if we could use them to
actually re:Inforce one another
to go faster, to innovate more,
and to have better compliant
and higher quality software?
So we're gonna talk with
you about an approach
that Ian and I have individually
done and we've worked
with other organizations on,
on how software excellence
makes compliance
more of a natural
outcome of your activity.
So before we dive into solutions,
we need to acknowledge,
well, maybe an uncomfortable reality.
The compliance approach that we all,
and I'm gonna group you in with me here,
that we've all inherited,
obviously wasn't designed
for modern software,
but it is being ruthlessly
applied to modern software.
So let's face some
uncomfortable truths about
what that's costing us
maybe, but the implications,
and I wanna start with a question
that might make you uncomfortable.
What if our compliance teams are actually,
well, what if they're
solving the wrong problem?
What if those hundreds
of hours that we're doing
and trying to document compliance,
what if we're just chasing shadows?
What if compliance could actually emerge
just solely from that good engineering?
So let me introduce you
to natural compliance.
It's how we learn to
stop fighting the forces
within these organizations.
When you build software with excellence,
compliance becomes automatic,
like a healthy tree bearing,
well fruit, no force,
no additional additives.
This isn't about lowering standards
and I wanna be clear on this.
I talked to lots of executives
in highly regulated spaces.
No one is talking about being reckless.
No one is talking about lowering quality.
In fact, I wanna raise quality,
as we go through and how we approach this.
It's about how we do that in achieve them
in a different way.
So let me dive into the details
on how these approaches,
well, maybe how they differ a little bit.
They aren't just different processes
in how we approach this.
They're fundamentally different
worlds in how we do this.
The traditional way of achieving
compliance is well you,
you build it, you you create it,
and then you scramble at the end.
Now maybe you guys are
better than I was my teams,
but you bolt compliance on in the end,
it's kind of like our souped
up car there over on the left.
This creates what I call,
well, documentation theater looks good.
You're required to have
it. It's impressive.
Look at this stack of documents I created,
and I won't go so far as maybe
to say it protects little,
but it doesn't actually drive
the results that we want to have.
You know, this natural compliance way,
builds excellent in,
compliance is engineered
into the process and the workflow
of doing software development.
And here's what's
transformed our thinking.
These aren't competing priorities.
Speed, quality, compliance,
the breakthrough that changes everything
is when we pursue them all together.
Automated testing helps
quality and provides
that compliance evidence.
Continuous monitoring, improved security
and satisfies those audit requirements.
But let's be honest about what traditional
compliance again is costing us.
In financial services, $30
million annually per company
is the estimate for compliance.
In healthcare, it's a
trillion dollars yearly,
of administrative burden
across the entire ecosystem.
We're trading speed and innovation
in this new modern AI world for theater,
not getting into actual production
and getting actual value.
And unfortunately guys, the
news is, it's getting worse.
98% of companies report
that their cost of
compliance it's going up.
61 billion just for in the United States
for financial crime compliance.
42% is labor costs, people
doing the manual work
that we could have systems doing.
And this trajectory is
just not sustainable.
Not only economically, but
from an innovation standpoint.
Again, in this new world that we live in,
and here's a number that
should drive every compliance
decision for every
dollar you don't invest,
you'll pay $2 and 71 cents in penalties.
This isn't theoretical,
it's from research across 53 companies.
It poses the question, why can we not?
We can't afford not to transform
and to make these changes,
and here's why we have this problem.
It's a fundamental mismatch in thinking.
Compliance wants a snapshot.
What'd your software look
like the day you deployed it
so they can stamp it, file it away forever
into a filing cabinet that
will only get accessed
when your auditor shows up and says,
prove to me that you did that.
Theater, but the reality
is, software's continuous.
It's not a photograph,
it's a movie. It deploys.
It should deploy daily, be
updated on a regular basis.
By the time we validate
and document the software,
it's already moved on.
At least it should have already moved on.
This isn't wishful thinking.
In fact, regulators worldwide,
they're beginning to endorse
this kind of automation.
I remember when I sat down
with my auditors from the FDA,
love my auditors from the FDA.
Class three regulated device.
I'm sure many of you experienced the same.
I talked to him and I said, guys,
you realize you're having me
spend more time proving to you
that I have good quality,
than actually investing in good quality.
Now the good news is we
didn't have quality problem
at Foundation Medicine, but
it was so far out of balance
and we're seeing them find this approach.
FDA is moving towards this
least burdensome approach.
They prefer finely testing
over documentation.
The regulatory world is
actually screaming at us
and telling us to modernize.
We in this industry just need to listen.
And for the first time ever,
those regulators are helping us go faster.
The FDA says, do more automated testing,
not write more documents.
Cloud platforms deliver
enterprise grade compliance
capabilities built into these solution,
digital native companies
are shipping daily.
Well in some cases
they're still validating,
amazingly, quarterly, the hidden costs
go just beyond operational
delays and rework
three to six month validation cycles.
Gosh, how many of those did I have?
Talented engineers, they wanna
build innovative solutions.
They don't want to write word documents.
Meanwhile, new companies
use modern approaches
to ship continuously.
The good news is,
Ian and I are gonna take you through
how you can adopt some of these practices.
And here's the pivot
that changes everything.
Stop fighting compliance
with more documentation and procedures.
Instead start achieving
it through engineering
excellence that works naturally.
Compliance becomes the result,
not the enemy of innovation.
And you might be wondering,
okay, sounds good.
I mean what's there to object to so far?
But how, how do I do this?
After working with dozens of companies,
we found a pattern that has worked,
four pillars that must align.
Fortunately, if you miss one,
everything's gonna fail together.
First is culture. Gosh, we've
heard it so many times, right?
In any transformation.
The culture is so critical and important,
but it's also important
how we think and organize
our teams to succeed.
We need the appropriate
mechanisms, the processes,
the procedures and how we operate this.
And then finally, you gotta
deliver, it's time to execute.
And let me walk you through each one
and how they build upon each other.
You know, you might think this is great,
maybe it works well in a
pharmaceutical industry
with the FDA, but every
regulatory industry
faces this same exact challenge.
Healthcare drowns in
documentation, financial services,
in their validation, the
root cause is identical.
So Ian and I now are gonna take you
through this solution foundation.
I'm gonna turn it over
to Ethan to break down
how we look at these cultural,
these organizational and these mechanisms
to help you guys understand
how we can achieve
that natural compliance.
Ian, I'll turn it over to you.
- Thank you Tom.
- Thank you.
- Alright, so as Tom said,
we have developed this
framework, AWS likes frameworks.
You may have heard of the
cloud adoption framework.
Well architected framework,
we like these frameworks.
Let's cover some of the foundations first.
So hopefully this will give
you an idea of, you know,
why we're developing this framework.
Some of the benefits we're
hoping that you can gain from it.
And again, this is not theory,
this is work we've done
with numerous customers
who kind of condensed that experience.
There's no accelerator for experience
and we've come up with these assets.
So let's just look at
some of the attributes
of what we consider one
of these more progressive organizations.
First thing, separation of concerns.
What we see, one of the main problems
is this kind of combination of quality,
product quality teams and IT quality.
We need to separate and we
need to pull them apart.
We need to allow product quality teams
to define the control
objectives, the requirements,
but then defer to IT quality teams
to actually decide how to
implement those controls.
The control framework
is the middle ground.
So that's where we collaborate.
Those two teams get together,
put their heads together,
define those control objectives,
but they leave the actual
implementation to the IT experts.
So we want to avoid situations
where quality is saying,
you need to demonstrate your
product quality controls
by producing a particular
document using this template.
We wanna shift away from
that old way of working.
Traditional quality management
kind of stemmed out of
the manufacturing world.
So you have a a production
line where product quality
was influenced by
consistency of the process.
So you log the processes
that ensures a certain level
of quality for that product.
But in IT every product is different.
Every IT system, the product
has different architectures,
different technologies.
So we need to adopt a
quality management system
with flexibility of process.
Stop locking it into a single
SOP mandated way of delivery.
Automate, automate, automate.
So if you're doing anything
twice, automate it.
If there's IT tooling that
can do the job, use it,
again, shifting away from manual processes
and document centric processes
that start to leverage the tooling
that any self-respecting
IT engineering team
is already using today.
What we wanna provide these dev teams
is what I'm calling freedom in a box.
So you provide them this environment
in which they can operate
quickly, efficiently,
they can provide business value,
they can focus on delivering
that business value
without really having to worry
about compliance all the time.
Try and take that lift
off their shoulders.
Few more attributes, shift left.
So in a lot of traditional
IT organizations
that compliance work is, is
kind of late in the cycle,
in the development cycle,
it's in the testing phase.
We wanna try and shift
as much of that up left.
You'll see from regulatory
agencies like the FDA,
that this idea of quality
by design is a big thing,
a culture of quality.
We want to instill that
into the IT processes
so that it's considered upfront.
System documentation.
Too often I see, you know, the
IT teams creating the system
documentation as part of their SDLC,
but there's then still
SOPs around these things.
So if you think about it,
when if you want to
control a manual process,
you have an SOP, fine.
Soon as you automate that process,
all of that information is transferred
into the system documentation,
and the workflows, and
the design documentation.
So in those situations you
should be retiring the SOP.
But still we see the two
being maintained in parallel.
Capture artifacts.
So as a natural byproduct of our work
of an engineering team,
we want to be generating
these compliance artifacts.
It's just naturally part
of the day-to-day work.
We don't wanna be doing extra activity
just for ticking compliance boxes.
The immutable pipeline
and immutable production.
We want to ensure that all
change goes through a pipeline.
We can demonstrate control
in that case, it's automated.
We are generating data,
which is our records,
our proof of compliance.
We want an immutable production.
We want to prevent people
from directly accessing
production accounts through
command line interface or the console.
'Cause as soon as you allow
that, you run the risk of drift
and things getting out of sync
with what you've already documented
in your system documentation.
So that's some of the
attributes we're looking for,
and that's why we kind of
put this framework together.
Now the benefit is that all
of these things get improved.
So speed increases by eliminating
handoffs between teams.
Quality improves, by finding issues early
rather than fixing them late.
The risk drops because
we're enforcing compliance.
We've shifted left,
we've built the controls
into our tooling and our processes.
Efficiency increases
because we're removing waste
from our processes.
And the talent stays or is attracted
to high performing engineering teams.
They get to focus on the cool stuff
rather than worrying about compliance.
But there's a cost benefit.
I mean, we've known this in the
IT industry for a long time.
The earlier you can identify
a defect or an issue,
and the quicker you can
fix it, the cheaper it is.
We've known this forever.
So you know, you fix something,
a problem in the requirements
and design say phase
you incur a cost of a dollar.
It's an order of magnitude greater
if you are fixing things in production.
The typical compliance phase
though is, is tail end of this.
It's maybe not production,
but certainly in the testing
and deployment phase, that's typically
where there's a lot of
compliance activity.
So it's a higher cost already.
We want to shift that left.
Now many of you here,
you already have a gold
mine of information.
I think pretty much any engineering team
these days is using tooling.
You know, JIRA for
requirements management,
confluence for documentation.
You've got CICD pipelines,
you've got automated testing happening.
These are all generating
data or IT records.
This is your compliance documentation,
your compliance evidence.
It makes no sense to
extract your requirements
from JIRA just to create a document.
Just manage them in the
tooling. Leverage the tooling.
Stop creating word documents
when you can manage
everything in this tooling.
So the fundamental equation
of trust is changing.
So we used to trust people and processes.
Now we're saying we'll trust
the tooling, the automation,
and that immutable evidence
that this tooling is generating.
So the automated controls,
the mutual evidence,
and now that equals trust.
So we're trying to change the mindset.
As Tom mentioned, that one
of the, the biggest things
that has to change first is culture.
So culture is what will derail
any transformation effort.
You know, you may have the
best tooling in the world,
great architecture, but 70%
of transformation efforts
fail because of culture.
So that's what the first pillar.
That's what we want to tackle
first. The hardest part.
And this was confirmed by McKinsey,
they did research again confirming
70% of transformations fail.
And the reason is not technology,
it's culture and resistant.
So you can buy the best tooling,
but with the wrong culture,
you're gonna have an expensive failure.
As I always like to say,
culture eats strategy for breakfast.
You can have the best plan in the world,
but without addressing culture
first, you're gonna fail.
So we're trying to shift
from a culture of compliance,
to a culture of quality.
I always contend that if you
adopt a culture of quality,
compliance is a natural byproduct.
So we want to shift from
this idea of checking
did we follow the SOP to,
does the system actually work?
This becomes kind of a new mantra
when you get back to the office on Monday.
If you've recovered from replay,
start to re:Inforce this with your teams.
Start to change their thinking.
So we first need to create
transformation army,
but it's a tiger team.
It's a small team.
We wanna find those champions
with the willingness
and eagerness to go out,
try and help with this transformation.
So I think it's 20%
roughly love automation.
If they do something twice,
they will automate it.
If 10% of quality
professionals have an interest
in growing beyond what their
role is currently defined as,
these are the people
you want to get first.
Work with them.
Those that are keen, avoid
the skeptics for now.
We'll deal with them in the future phase.
And their mission, this of this team
is to automate the compliance checks,
and we want a continuous flow
of these compliance checks
coming out of this team.
So we want to show working
systems not slides.
Now this is a practice
that has transformed
dozens of cultures.
It's proven to work.
Again, we worked with a lot of customers,
and it's around demos.
So weekly, 30 minute demo
shows something working.
A working system will build trust
faster than slides ever will.
Actually working systems.
So start with your team
in the first few weeks,
try and build some of these automations,
and another few weeks,
show it to your management.
Maybe around 12.
Actually invite auditors in,
show them what you're
doing, get them on board.
Now no framework would be
complete without metrics measures.
So what gets measured gets done.
But what gets celebrated gets repeated.
So you can track the leading indicators,
automation coverage, demo
attendance, but celebrate them.
Celebrate those monthly wins,
promote these champions,
have it improve their career.
You know, encourage them
to start adding to this.
Again, the goal is to make
compliance so automated
that nobody really
thinks about it anymore.
That may kind of sound kind of contrary
to this whole career progression.
So you need to celebrate
these wins, these automations.
Link their careers to these.
Okay, so we've covered culture,
hopefully we've nailed that.
We've got people, the mindset is changing.
We then need to match
the organization to it.
So this demo culture creates
something pretty powerful,
which is people wanting to automate.
When the teams see the automation working,
they naturally start thinking
about automation first,
rather than the old manual processes.
That mindset shift is starting to happen,
and we need to start
breaking down these silos,
avoid silos from fighting
each other, turf wars,
and try and bring them together.
So you can't reorganize people
that don't want to change,
which is why culture must come first.
But once teams start to see
this automation working,
and that mind shift starts to happen,
you start to see them no longer
trying to defend their territory,
but start to ask how can we work together?
They're seeing the value.
This is when you can start
to kind of break those silos
by embedding compliance
experts in your teams.
So in in several of our frameworks,
we always like to promote
this concept of a product
based operating models
where you build the team
around a product and they
have all the resources
that they need.
So there's none of these
handoffs between organizations.
Same concept here,
but now we're bringing
compliance experts into the team.
So they're no longer a review step
after you've done some work,
they're actively embedded in the team.
They're providing input.
They have a vested
interest in this product
working and being compliant
by design from day one.
One of the things you
always see is, is you know,
we mentioned waste or lack of efficiency.
So the traditional org structures
often slow things down.
Kill speed, innovation, they create waste,
because every kind of
handoff introduces delay.
Two to four weeks information gets lost.
It's like playing Chinese whispers.
It's not working. There we go.
Every handoff degrades information.
It introduces waste.
So when your compliance
team sits in one building,
your dev teams are in another,
you are unable to answer the question
of how can we go fast and
meet these requirements?
The questions kind of drop between
the cracks between organizations.
So we need to rethink how
we organize these things.
What does transformation
look like on the ground?
So quality professionals get
brought into the product teams.
So there's no handoff anymore.
The compliance engineers
sit in the standups
with your dev teams.
As part of their career
progression maybe they also start
to write code, start small.
They look at automation.
They are trying to
automate their own checks.
They really start to get
into this automation,
automation, automation mentality.
The old review gates start to disappear
because it's, again, it's all built in.
As I said, world transformation
starts to happen.
The skills start to shift as they upskill,
the decision rights happen
within the product team
and you start to see a positive impact
on these success metrics.
Again, no framework is complete
without governance models in this case.
But here we want to try and
split the what from the how.
So we want quality teams
to define the standards
and the requirements or set
those control objectives,
yet defer to IT teams that
really understand automation
and the technical
implementation to figure out
the best way implementing those controls.
The key is both sides working
together in real time,
not sequentially handing
over but together,
and creating this cycle much smoother
than this old school handoff approach.
Now I mentioned earlier things
like the cloud adoption framework,
product based operating models.
A foundational piece is the platform team.
So you know, an example is
to create your landing zone.
You have a cloud center of
excellence sitting around that.
The platform team is an
enabler of multiple dev teams.
So they start to take
some of that compliance,
heavy lifting off the
shoulders of dev teams,
build capabilities into
the underlying platform.
This could be account vending,
baselining your accounts.
You've got that, you know,
freedom within the box
because you are giving them
an account that's already
got all the guard guardrails around it.
You can create building blocks.
So these are pre-approved infrastructures,
code like cloud formation templates,
made available to them
through a service catalog.
It's things that they can start to use
shifting towards self-service.
The platform team becomes
a great enabler of this.
There's going to be some
upskilling I mentioned,
those compliance engineers.
We need to establish some
training paths for them again,
linked to their own career progression.
Those compliance engineers
that used to just handle
documentation all of the time,
start to shift them
towards automation experts.
Teach 'em basic coding, teach
'em the automation tooling,
how to use testing tools.
All of these things make them aware
of how CICD pipelines
really help compliance.
Again, get them embedded
in the product team
but upskill them so that they understand
what we're talking about.
So here's an idea of your first week.
Again, when you get back
to the office on Monday,
you're fully recovered from replay.
Pick some kind of control
that you want to implement.
Maybe you want to turn on GIT signing
so that you are starting
to generate evidence
whenever there's a
commit in your Git repo.
Create that first compliance test.
Start to collect that
evidence on the Wednesday,
basic dashboarding.
So now that you've got
the data and the evidence,
create a dashboard to show it.
Demo to the auditor.
Week one, you already have one
control potentially automated
in collaboration with your IT teams.
This is gonna start that flywheel
of producing more and
more of these controls.
Okay, so we've got culture, done tick,
got the organization hopefully aligned,
something great happens then,
the technical work and
generating this evidence starts
to become natural.
And these aren't theoretical concepts,
they're patterns that are
working in production today
with many of our customers.
Well, let's look at more
into these mechanisms.
We'll kind of do a compare and contrast.
When compliance is automated,
it almost becomes invisible.
It's just again,
a natural byproduct of
your day-to-day work.
It's happening naturally.
It's just part of your
dev team's day-to-day work
through proper automation.
However, it was a case
where you do manual testing.
So your validation cycles
never actually catch up
to your rate of delivery.
So by the time you finished validating,
your systems already
changed, Tom mentioned this.
It's the same even if you
buy off the shelf software,
you install it, you start
your validation cycle,
you report a bug to the vendor,
they have to fix it, patch it,
you've gotta restart your cycle again,
it's just this never
ending pain of validation,
never keeping up with the pace of change.
So we need to change that.
When you get to the audit,
every audit is kind of this
archeological investigation
into piles of documentation
that's already out of date.
It's painful.
So basically we really
need to encourage, I dunno,
test driven development, test automation,
anything to make testing
faster, so that every commit,
every release, is getting
validated every single time.
Requirements in code may
be a step too far for some,
but really the message
is that requirements
don't need to be in a Word document.
Doesn't that be to be any
user requirement specification
in a set template format.
You could at least store
your requirements in JIRA,
manage them there.
Demonstrate control over
your requirements management
using the tooling.
If you are having to
extract your requirements
to create a document, something
is wrong with your process,
talk with your engineer,
your quality engineers.
Every time your code changes,
you're gonna have| to
update the requirements.
You could actually use them.
You probably see it in
the in the hallways.
Anything to do with KIRA,
spec driven development
is a great new tool.
You should really look into
it where you are capturing
the requirements in a specification.
KIRAs helping you develop those.
Again, it's requirements is
embedded in the code almost.
What's interesting is that the regulations
have been around forever.
They haven't changed in many, many years,
but what they're actually asking for,
it used to require specialized systems
to capture those audit
trails, to have e-signatures.
These capabilities are now built
into your regular IT tooling.
Yet we're still using old school processes
and document centric processes,
and not using the capabilities
in the tooling we already have.
So we need to shift.
You are already generating
all the evidence.
So again, as we mentioned,
that tool chain from
requirements management
linked to your test management tools,
CICD pipelines that are telling you
what was deployed and when,
defect management tools to
automated testing, you name it,
you have that plethora of
evidence already in your tooling.
We need need to bring it together.
There isn't a kind of an
integrated tool set that brings
everything across your
entire SDRC into one place.
So let's start to draw that
data together into a compliance
data lake or you know,
data virtualization.
Pull it together so you can automatically
generate things like trace matrices.
It's very easy once you have the data.
Turn every system into
a compliance generator.
Start by inventorying what you have today.
Odds are you have requirements management.
You're probably using CICD pipelines.
You're performing security scans.
So start to inventory what you have,
and start to pull that
together into one place
with the goal of auto
generating reports if need be.
Or answering questions
that are gonna come from your inspectors.
Make your pipeline your validator.
So think about the
current validation cycle.
You're probably doing it quarterly.
It's very stressful.
We are striving for
validation on every commit.
So you commit something, it
gets with a pull request,
it triggers the CRCD pipeline.
The pipeline has all
the compliance checks,
does automated testing.
You are validating after every release.
We don't wanna be scrambling
every quarter to do this thing.
Again, it's natural part of
your normal way of working.
Apply this to infrastructure as well.
So one of the big things with cloud
was the introduction of
infrastructure as code.
So what I've described was, you know,
we all do it with code, do it
the same with infrastructure.
Now we have a cloud formation template,
we do a pull request.
It gets reviewed approved,
triggers a pipeline,
gets deployed through cloud formation,
or terraform your choice.
But we have the same
mechanism now of controlling
infrastructure as we did with code,
and it's generating evidence.
So we had the old IQ, OQ,
PQ and regulated systems.
That whole infrastructure
qualification step,
is now automatable and
arguably you no longer need
to do verification steps afterwards
if you've already got
that pipeline in place
and an immutable production
because you've already tested
the tooling and proven that
whatever you feed into it
in your cloud formation template
is what is getting deployed.
So you've quickly speed up
that verification of infrastructure.
Think about how we
discover compliance issues
in your systems today.
It's usually during an audit,
where the auditor asks some question
and you have an oh sugar
moment, we missed something.
It's a little late.
So we want to again shift
towards automated monitoring,
watching for Drift.
We want to be able to detect
any compliance issues.
Well in advance of any audit.
Then we get to execution.
This is where the rubber eats the road
and I'll hand it back to Tom.
- Thanks Ian.
You know I'm excited
about this and you know,
you bring together the culture
of the organization and the mechanisms.
You know, really what we're
trying to build is a solution
that allows you to use your
current requirement tool.
Maybe it's JIRA, maybe
it's something else.
Just do the documentation in there.
Use your architecture tool,
variety of different tools.
Document your information inside of there.
Having the automated pipeline
that captures the information,
executes the automated test,
captures the evidence of the
automated test and inputs
all of that into a compliance
documentation automatically.
So that your engineers
who are already doing these activities
of designing your software,
gathering requirements for your software,
building your software,
checking in code for your
software, testing your software,
getting the results from the test.
These are things that they
should already be doing every day
just to write your software.
And if you do it right, all
of that can then generate
the compliance software or
the compliance capabilities
that we need so that we can
execute all of this at speed.
You know, we built the
culture where teams, you know,
hopefully wanna automate is part of this.
You've structured the
organization the way you want.
Now comes the part that
feels scary, executing,
putting this into production,
but here's what changes.
You're not hoping it works.
You know this will work,
because this is how you've
been writing the software,
how you've been approaching it.
We've seen teams spend
six months validating
their validation approach.
Congratulations.
They want everything perfect
before they start anything at all.
And again, I'm not telling
you to be reckless,
but their systems are accumulating debt,
their competitors are out flanking them.
And the cost isn't just in time,
it's in the momentum of the things
that you never even get a chance to do.
So 90 days is the
transformation sweet spot
for where we want to target
long enough for real results.
Short enough to maintain focus.
You don't have to be great to start,
but you must start to be great.
This is something that
you will iterate on,
as Ian broke down for you.
Small incremental steps
for your teams to take,
fast enough that you can't overthink this.
Give your team short term deliverables.
Even though we might be going
for a 90 day project on it.
I want to see something today,
I wanna see something tomorrow.
Give your team the impetus, the drive,
the energy on this to innovate and again,
to not overthink it, start
with what you control.
Maybe get your Git
signatures working correctly,
as Ian mentioned you know, set
up that first compliance test
and build that simple dashboard.
And each week as you iterate over this,
you will build increasing
amounts of confidence.
You know, consider where
your team spend time today,
that manual compliance work.
Go after those things religiously.
Developers waiting for approvals.
Gosh, if I ever heard,
you know the the term,
I need wet ink signature on a paper.
Again, I'll lose my mind.
Trying to push something into production,
but we can't put it into production
'cause you need to get
someone to sign off on it,
and they're at their
daughter's softball game.
We live in a digital world.
How can we evolve past that
and move past these things?
And it's through this automation,
through these automated capabilities.
You see though, you know,
different stakeholders care about
different aspects of this.
You know, your CEO likely thinks
about your market position
in competitive philosophy,
velocity, your CFO,
well, they wanna understand
the cost and the savings
and the risk exposure, but
your engineering leaders
want to know how can we go faster?
How can we innovate?
Unfortunately, the quality teams lose,
think that they're gonna lose
control in this automation.
But what I've experienced and seen
is they actually gain more control,
because they have input and control
into the process and
the ability themselves
to directly influence what happened.
You see, I've seen teams get stuck waiting
for the perfect automation plan.
They wanna solve everything at once.
Others, well, they buy
expensive tools and things.
What actually works, again,
going back to what Ian said,
pick that one issue, get it working,
and then let the success spread
those small visible wins.
Guys, we've done this in every
transformation we've led.
This is no different
than how this happens.
Scaling too fast can also be a problem.
You get excited after
those early successes,
but you wanna roll it out everywhere.
All of our compliance gonna
change the whole organization.
Slow down.
Each team will surface new
requirements and new issues,
move progressively, move with purpose,
move to that 90 day target.
But don't do it to the extreme.
The temptation is to
scale too or scale fast.
But the teams that rush into
those organizational wide
solutions, they often hit a
problem that they can't solve.
You see one team, well
they learn how to actually
first start that operating
three to five your next teams,
well, they show whether
or not your approach
will actually scale and actually
whether or not it'll work.
Doing it once is good.
As Ian mentioned, get the momentum,
but I gotta push more people to figure out
how well this scales,
but do that thoughtfully and deliberately.
Before I get to that
organizational wide rollout,
you're gonna know that this is working,
when certain things are happening,
teams outside your pilot will ask
how they can join what you're doing.
It happened to me.
I had teams coming up to me going,
all the cool kids are
doing this new compliance
documentation and they love
it, and do I become a cool kid?
Your weekly demos will grow in attendance
without you requiring people to come,
and your auditors will ship
from skeptical to curious.
I had my auditor come up to me and say,
I didn't when you started this,
I didn't think you were
gonna be successful.
And I didn't believe in it,
but I am impressed with where we are,
and I wish I'd participated
in it from the beginning.
We need to bring those minds
and those people all along with us.
And as Ian mentioned,
bring them into the process
on this and not have them sit outside.
You know, I know a common
fear is that your regulators
won't accept automated compliance,
but modern regulatory guidance again,
encourages this automation,
encourages using this tooling,
you gain more visibility.
I had so much control and visibility.
I knew exactly what we
deployed into production,
why we did it, the requirements
for it, how it was designed,
how it was tested, the
results of those tests.
Every single time we put
something into production,
and when I talk to my auditors,
I'm like, what else do you want?
I mean, assuming it
resulted in quality, right?
Which is the end game.
But I was like, what do you want?
That's where we want to get to.
But yeah, you're gonna hear objections.
Everyone who tries this, my experience,
Ian probably can say the same thing,
has heard the same things.
We tried automation before,
it didn't work for us.
But that's usually because
the tools came first
without thinking of the
workflow in the process,
Ian and I gave you a little,
how you can capture requirements in JIRA
and move that through the process.
Each one of you has a unique process.
We're happy to work with you on that.
But you have that unique
process and that's because,
well it's, you're all unique,
so start small, iterate on this.
The fear of breaking
compliance. Well it's real.
So be thoughtful, be careful,
you're not switching this overnight.
I ran mine in parallel,
so I still followed the
traditional waterfall,
word-based, documentation,
you know, all those things.
Well, I implemented this
automated process and I showed
not only to my internal compliance teams,
but the external compliance teams.
The old way came up with this,
the new way came up with that.
And when we point to whether or not,
they're documented control
over the environment,
exhibiting quality systems,
they were the same.
And it took time.
I had to keep going back,
keep showing 'em, keep demonstrating.
And eventually they said,
yeah, yeah, yeah, we're good.
Get rid of that other stuff.
You are gonna go through
these same things.
So we've covered a lot.
We've talked about culture, organizations,
mechanisms and execution.
Each piece in this puzzle matters,
but together they create
something well, bigger.
Culture makes the teams want to automate.
So help them understand
why we need to move
through compliance theater
and quality excellence.
Build that transformation
army as Ian talked about,
and show those working systems.
This isn't about slides and and
and beautiful presentations.
It's about showing things
at work and have those KPIs,
great name and shame board.
Here's the teams that have implemented
fully automated compliance.
Here's the ones that haven't.
No one wants to be on the
bottom end of the leaderboard.
Then move into the organization.
We want to get to instead
of silos to squads,
we need ownership of this.
I used to tell my
compliance people their job
was not to make sure I
wrote compliance software.
Their job was to ensure that I delivered
compliance software into production.
We need them to all have
the same goal and objective,
the engineering teams, the
compliance teams on this,
and we need to empower
these teams on how to do it.
But we can still do
that by having control.
And then we need to
move to the mechanisms.
As Ian mentioned, every tool and system
that you're using today
probably is creating evidence
and proof of how it's being operated.
Implement controls over that.
Your pipeline then becomes your validator,
your control system.
My pipeline was under
the most change control
out of anything I had,
because my pipeline was
the way that I guaranteed
that all of my systems worked correctly.
And get into that self documentation
and extract that information.
And then we wanna move on to execution.
Focus on that 90 day sprint,
but focus on how you can
have that small value
and incrementally grow as you do this,
as you run these in parallel
the traditional way,
and the new natural compliance way.
And then ultimately I think you'll see
that you have a lot of success in this.
I appreciate your time here today,
these QR codes as well as
the information up there,
the contact information for Ian and I.
We would both be happy to
continue the conversation
with you guys, to answer
any further questions
as you guys begin on this journey.
We will also be spending
some time here afterwards
after the presentation
if you want to come up.
If any of you guys have any questions.
Guys, thank you very much for your time.
I know it's been a long day,
and thanks for hanging out with us here
at the end of the day today.
Thank you very much.
(audience applauding)